[Music]
early 1800s it's the middle of the
Napoleonic Wars in the middle of Europe
and it's the middle of the night one
captain Charles Barbee a of Napoleon's
army is trying to relay a message to one
of his troops but sending written
communications to the front line can be
deadly for the recipient lighting a
candle to read the misses can give away
their position to the enemy in a moment
of vision Barbee a pokes a series of
holes into a sheet of paper with his
blade creating a coded message that can
be deciphered by fingertips even in the
pitch black the merits of his so-called
night writing are never acknowledged by
the military but in 1821 bar ba
approaches the Royal Institute for blind
youth in Paris in the hopes that they
might find a use for his innovative new
communication method they're a
precocious teen by the name of Louis
Braille does just that
Louie spends the next several years
improving on Barbie A's idea creating an
organized alphabet fitting into a six
table standardized so the system catches
on today Braille is the universally
accepted system of writing for the blind
adapted for more than 130 languages
you
[Music]